françois cluzet bonsoir regarde l'île de
cuba qui sort qui s'appelle un tour de
manège avec la petite juliette binoche
grandes sinon tu vas nous demande alors
comme à 20h30
il ya quinze ans j'ai rencontré ce mic
pradines aspect prêtre au théâtre j'ai
travaillé avec lui ensuite
mise en scène qu'il a plu au théâtre je
suis ans devenu son ami on s'est quittés
on s'est retrouvés et puis un jour m'a
demandé si qu'est ce qu'ils devaient
faire de ce script qu'il avait eu à
faire à deux producteurs qui pour des
raisons pour d'autres avaient laissé
tomber le fils a dit est ce que j'en ai
créé un autre je devais tout je fais ce
qui est finalement j'avais tellement
envie de faire un film avec lui et puis
aussi qu'ils fassent son premier film on
a parlé de faire ensemble
autant ces deux personnages gaal et elsa
py toi tu un peu à la zone elle aussi
pis elle te quitte
et toi tu est attiré vers le cinéma et
je la revois elle disparaît lauréats par
l re disparaît et finalement c'est un
peu une métaphore sur le cinéma c'est à
dire c'est un peu la faute à un peu le
spectateur est réelle la star oui c'est
vrai mais c'est une rupture coin ses
dires elle se barre j'arrive pas à la
retenir si jamais je lai au téléphone ou
si je la vois c'est toujours avec le
sentiment qu'elle va disparaître il
réplique comme ça du film qui dit j'ai
peur que tout s'écroule si tu t'en vas
ouais c'est ça qui vivons pas c'est ça
que je veux d'abord commencé quand même
d'être ici kutesa à t'en fais moi
confiance
c'est pas toi qui peux rien c'est tout
partout moi j'ai des bonnes nouvelles tu
ne l'ès pas parler tu me fais aucune
confiance pour annuler campagne dans la
campagne
calme-toi moi aussi j'ai pas laisser la
campagne chez mourir
déconne pas à coup j'ai vu le titre pour
le film ferme les yeux bougent pas
ouvrir
j'ai quoi le type là monteyne il part en
italie pendant trois semaines il m'a
laissé son appart
tu comprends un super appart avec une
ligne de téléphone dans chaque pièce
voilà ça c'est des clés et après après
je sais pas si je fais le film j'aurais
plein de thunes je tomberais au bout du
monde
ouais c'est inventer une ville géniale
on ira où
peu avant la clôture a du choix je
t'achèterai un globe qui choisira ou tu
veux
coutu
il ya un autre film qui est sorti au
mois d'avril le scénario c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui se fait gauler
en asie avec 300 g 2 h
et puis un avocat qui alan bates qui
vient de voir qui va voir bruel call
intello toi tu as un peu à la zone nord
de la france puis dit voilà le mec il a
pris il est condamné à mort pour 300 g
par contre si vous acceptez de dire l'un
et l'autre que vous aviez 100 grammes à
vous ce sera deux ans chacun donc la
question c'est de savoir est-ce qu'on
par an est-ce qu'on part en thaïlande
faire deux ans pour sauver le mec de la
mort est-ce qu'on récupère son pote
quand il est en tôle où est-ce qu'on
laisse en finir là bas puisque c'est un
problème de partage de l'open quoi
prochaine levée de peine pour pour la
cause au délit quoi s'est élevé à
stanislas a été levée dans une ambiance
assez religieuse disons c'est vrai que
tu es à ces croyants c'est à dire que
j'ai un jour je me suis rendu compte
qu'entre ne pas croire et croire je
préférais croire las calles parce que
j'ai pas lu tout pari de pascal
ben oui c'est ça alors tu fais des
signes de croire dans le tournage non
mais je suis pas matador non mais
franchement moi je fais d'autres choses
par exemple je me recule de 3 pas au
moment où j'étais ici qu'il faut que je
marque de 3 pas des choses comme ça
aussi bête est parfois un peu
superstitieux quand même hein tu dis
toujours je fais des signes de quoi les
gens croient que je cherche un
décapsuleur c'est bien la capsule est ce
que tu as dit un acteur c'est quelqu'un
qui aime sincèrement sur commande
ce qui fait qu'ils tombent amoureux
toutes tes partenaires au cinéma
en général tu tousses la conscience
professionnelle très loin non c'est pas
ça c'est que si on me demande d'aimer
mon partenaire comme par exemple ça
m'est arrivé avec dexter gordon ou tout
le rôle consiste à aimer ce type ce
compositeur pour qu'il se remette à
composer bon bah le problème
il fallait que je n'aime la chance que
j'ai eue c'est quand il ouvre la porte
de son appartement à new york
on y va acter rien et tu regardes ce
type les yeux ce qui fait de m il est
immense et aussi dans ses yeux je me
doute qu'il est immense quoi oui et il
est enfin tu es quand même tombé
amoureux fanny ardant par exemple et du
mal
l'oublier parce que aussi les grandes
actrices de cinéma sont peut-être les
plus belles femmes qui perd aussi un
petit pincement au coeur mais il n'y a
pas de placement de fait s'il ya sud ont
déjà envie d'aimer son partenaire parce
que la qualité de l'acteur qu'il est et
puis aussi la fin quel est l'homme qu'il
est
mais binoche juliette c est très
particulier c'est une actrice jeune très
jeune c'est une mais je dis que c'est
très particulier parce que c'était avec
sandrine bonnaire les deux actrices
jeunes avec lesquels j'ai joué sympa les
vrais acteurs et surtout quand on est
partenaire aussi mais dans ce cas là
c'est bon t'es épouse et chantal perrin
c'est vrai que c'est la fin de ton
meilleur pote
ah oui ça a été la femme de mon meilleur
pote c'est un projet c'est ça être hamon
avait été dur parce que j'étais présente
mais enfin tu me comprends ces gens et
c'est ça les travaux c'est ne pas
décider si c'est la femme d'un tel ou si
c'est la fille du maire aussi c'est un
but c'est que lunettes noires bon fait
des interviews à thème alors tu payes
portrait chinois
mais le portrait chinois si je te dis
par exemple s'il était une fleur alors
tu me dis pas je serai une orchidée ou
un bleu et ou alors là on va faire
lentilles portrait chinois tpr est oui
si tu étais une injure merde allez vous
faire [ __ ] tous c'était d une
infirmité une infirmière un médecin
je suis un assassin c'était un dictateur
ou
je serai mal luné schrey serait la
maîtresse d'hitler surprenant au sérieux
c'était un vice je suis en lice c'est
une guerre ou guerre la prochaine c'est
un accident encore moi même en voiture
très très vite
un soir pour rire bien allumé une
cicatrice en plus de ses pas
une autre montre des cicatrices
j'en ai une j'ai pu faire croire un jour
que c'était un coup de couteau qu'on va
donner dans le ventre un vrai dire
c'était une hernie et districts et
villes vos noms et il faut est-ce qu'on
peut raconter sa part exhorté à
quelqu'un qui nous admirons qui a envie
de vous connaître ou que vous avez envie
de séduire par ce que je la trouvais
jolie au bo bun au moins j'ai reçu un
coup de couteau dans le bas haut salat
fourche pas assez amusant c mais
clairement et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou